hollywood geht es mir jetzt zugeschaltet
sie ist rechtsanwältin für reiserecht
ganz herzlich willkommen for much also
das ganze
ralf hat angesprochen gilt dann
offensichtlich und ist ab gezielt auf
urlauber jetzt zur herbst reisezeit zu
den herbstferien was muss ich jetzt wenn
ich mit meiner 45 sechsköpfigen familie
verreisen möchte was muss ich denn da
und jetzt beachten und ich komme aus
einem risikogebiet oder weiß es
vielleicht gar nicht
ja also als erstes ist wirklich an
gesagt dass man ab checkt beim
robert-koch-institut ob der eigene
wohnort nämlich der es entscheidend als
risikogebiet gilt das sozusagen der
erste schritt und der zweite schritt der
war bisher und ja ich würde sagen wird
es auch noch sein sich anzugucken wie
die regelung im urlaubsort sind denn das
beherbergungs verbot das meint wirklich
nur den touristischen aufenthalt in
hotels oder ähnlichem
die bundesländer können trotzdem noch
quarantine regelung separat einführen
die können sonderregelung für
familienbesuche einführen also sprich so
richtig klar ist damit noch immer nicht
wie es in den einzelnen bundesländern
aussieht es ist ein bisschen mehr
klarheit
gut dann könnte ich wenn es um hotels
geht könnte ich da etwas über airbnb
oder
couchsurfing führt das auch drunter oder
wäre das ein schlupfloch nein ist kein
schlupfloch also die bisherigen
bundesländern die das ja eigentlich auch
fast alles schon geregelt hatten die
hatten in der regel auch schon einen
beherbergungs verbot also ich würde
jetzt mal so schätzen zwei drittel
ungefähr hatten genau das sowieso schon
geregelt und die hatten auch schon ganz
klar gestellt dass damit jetzt nicht nur
hotels gemeint sind sondern eben auch
ferienwohnungen campingplätzen oder
ähnliches also es gab da ein paar
ausnahmen wenn man sozusagen eine
vielleicht eine eigentumswohnung der
hatte die man regelmäßig nutzt aber ich
sag mal wenig schlupflöcher im
eigentlichen sinne eigentlich nicht da
lassen sie uns jetzt mal ein szenario
aufbauen also die familie hat den urlaub
geplant für die herbstferien hat gebucht
ist noch nicht in aus einem risikogebiet
aber just zwei tage vor den herbstferien
sind sie risikogebiet was dann ja
tatsächlich ist es dann so dass das ganz
genau als risikogebiet gilt also ist
nicht die buchung entscheiden sondern
der moment in dem ich in den urlaub
fahre aber das gute für urlauber ist
eigentlich sozusagen dieses verbot weil
man sich dann zumindest nicht unter die
kosten sorgen machen muss das war in
einigen bundesländern jetzt auch unklar
so nach dem motto ich kann jetzt darf
jetzt gar nicht fahren muss ich trotzdem
meinen hotel bezahlen mit einem
beherbergungs verbot ist zumindest diese
sorge vom tisch das hotel kann ja dann
in dem moment gar nicht den vertrag
erfüllen es darf sie nicht beherbergen
weil sie aus einem risikogebiet kommen
und dann haben sie zumindest die
gewissheit dass sie eben ja gott sei
dank da nicht auch noch den urlaub
bezahlen müssen den sie nicht antreten
können mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bild schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren